T
WE ARE MONITORING WHILE THIS IS
GOING ON, INCLUDING CONFIRMED
RESULTS THAT JEN PSAKI, THE
PRESIDENT SECRETARY ANNOUNCED
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE THAT SHE
HAS CONTRACTED COVID-19 AND SHE
WAS JUST TESTED POSITIVE.
SHE'S HAD TWO SOCIALLY DISTANCED
MEETINGS WITH THE PRESIDENT IN
RECENT DAYS SO NOT A DIRECT
CONTACT VIA THEIR STATEMENT BUT
WILL NOT BE TRAVELLING, SHE JUST
ANNOUNCED, WITH THE PRESIDENT TO
HIS, ON HIS TRIP TO EUROPE THIS
WEEK, JOHN.
>> John: THE SECOND TIME IT HAS
HAPPENED, A NUMBER OF MONTHS AGO
SHE HAD COVID AS WELL, TESTED
NEGATIVE UP UNTIL ONE DAY WHEN
SHE SUDDENLY TESTED POSITIVE, ON
A SATURDAY SHE TESTED POSITIVE
AND FOREWENT A TRIP AT THAT
POINT.
IT GOES TO SHOW WE HAVE NOT HAD
A LOT OF NEWS ABOUT COVID LATELY
BUT REMAINS AN ISSUE IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND WITH THE BA2
VARIANT IN EUROPE AND PROBABLY
CIRCULATIN